put a little call out here to like
fellow creators you want to re-platform
this guy it's just it's just like weird
that's the guy with the um the dildo
the tapes have been getting come after
by everybody since they got canceled you
know ksi went after them i think he was
joking apparently h3 h3 ethan l3 klein
is obviously ecstatic and logan paul was
celebrating on his podcast just last
week of how excited he is that tate got
banned he's so glad that he doesn't have
a platform meanwhile this dude's made
some of the most heinous mistakes on
social media and has scammed millions of
dollars that's the guy with the um the
dildo no that's a different guy that's
the difference well now that i said it
about logan paul it's true right because
everything we see on the internet is
true right yeah exactly pop the fact
checker uh yeah and also the tates just
uh reacted to us in this video this
should be posted the day before you're
seeing this one so go check that out too
still
we're both we're boys with the tates now
we're going to that party when they're
throwing a party for sneako so we're
gonna go to it could be lit i gotta buy
a new dress and uh yeah i don't feel
like platforming this guy the social
media platforms have made it very clear
how they feel about this guy right put a
little call out here to like fellow
creators
you want to re-platform this guy
anyone logan paul the youtube star who
has millions of young followers under
fire for posting an alarming video
showing the body of a person who took
their own life this has been to be
honest with you for those of you that
don't know and i'm sure you don't know
when he went to japan he made a youtube
video and he went to like the suicide
forest and there was someone hanging
from a tree and he included it in the
video and he made it the thumbnail of
this dead person hanging in a tree oh my
god so there's a there's a suicide
forest what does that mean is that it's
just it's just like a horrible place
to commit suicide in japan yeah so he
went to it made a video out of it and
then put a thumbnail there's people
killing themselves he used it and then
what happened after that did the whole
world just they just flipped out on him
yeah he was younger he was younger and
uh yeah he just got absolutely flamed by
planet earth life never been
hated by the whole world he was top g he
was the guy that could show you how to
do it youtube you got rules and i'm here
to follow and i ain't [ __ ] with any i
i like the platform right and the steak
do we have a deal mr reagan i know this
steak doesn't exist when i put it in my
mouth the matrix is telling my brain
that it is
juicy
and delicious
you know what i realize
ignorance is bliss yeah we're caught in
the nature oh that statement is so true
deeper you look into everything and how
pretty much everyone every government
structure and all business and like ever
the way everything truly works it's just
such bs not the way it's it's truly
portrayed it's really like it just makes
your life more stressful having like
looking into it and you're like wow this
doesn't make sense this doesn't make
sense yeah ignorance is bliss
[ __ ] it's great here there's a state
case the stage is there
then we have a deal
as much as he talks about being outside
of the matrix
now you're outside the club and we hear
you complaining that you can't get in
that is actually the exact opposite yeah
he's uh he's fine you're out of the club
yeah yeah we're out of the club because
we realized the club sucked it was a
lame club where you got hazed and you
had
like it's literally come out that the
government tells these social media
companies what they can and cannot put
out what they can censor with what is
the truth how can you believe anything
anymore it killed socrates because it's
corrupting the youth
you don't want young men to look up to
anybody the left wants to turn young men
into young women yeah you have these
huge tech companies censoring outright
literally erasing somebody that's wrong
but they're a company why can't they
private companies ban people well first
of all you didn't break any rules
actually no i disagree with you they
can't because where does it end where if
you can just ban anybody where does it
end their rules are if you if you follow
the guidelines then you then you don't
get banned you didn't break any of the
guidelines so what's next if you're so
let's say what if if you're a boston
bruins fans can they just say if you're
a boston bruins fan you get banned right
i get your i get your point he didn't
break the rules they banned him it's i
think ethically morally wrong i think as
a private company they do have the right
to do it but i also think that these
social i've said it before these social
media platforms have become almost can
have not even almost have become akin to
utilities water electricity gas and in
as a line of communication they are now
utilities and so they do need to follow
some they need new rules where they're
following some government regulations
and following the constitution of you
know free access free speech and those
things until that happens they do have
the right to get rid of anybody no
matter how much you and i disagree with
it i think they're [ __ ] and i think
it's so corrupt that the government is
going in and telling them what to cover
up for political purposes as we learned
with zuckerberg and the fbi and the
hunter bride and laptop story but they
still have the right to do it under the
law right now until we change that so
right or wrong it's legal right now we
need to change it some dude just threw
twitter that got banned and he was like
the first one to win get reinstated and
he won the whole lawsuit well is it
because they violated their own policies
and he made it because when you agree to
their policies you're basically signing
a contract so if i agree with them
here's our deal and they break their end
to the deal then we have a legal dispute
that we can get into so what's good
maybe what deals to tape we don't know
so i'm sure taste lawyers are looking
into it but he doesn't even want to go
back to them he doesn't care everyone
followed him to rumble anyways you know
it would be cool though if he sued them
in one the agents of the matrix have
been busy sitting around tables
talking like cowards about you about me
sitting there doing whatever susan tells
them to do you know
i don't really normally do reply videos
but
what i witnessed unfortunately when it
was forwarded to me
was the hardest cope
the biggest coward [ __ ] i have ever
seen in my life
i have no problem with people
disagreeing with me and having a
different opinion that's normal that's
part of adulthood however when people
pretend that they don't agree with you
purely because they are afraid that's
some cigar cutter oh my god yeah i
didn't even notice that
because they are cowards just that's the
machete sad to see
and that's what this entire
there was a little [ __ ]
in you know the guy who who was the guy
who begged the girls to bum him with
dildos and suck the dildos oh uh
true jordy yeah so in true jordy's
studio
logan who's his friend
funnily enough
decides to sit down
and purport absolute [ __ ] fallacy in
an attempt to justify
us being banned from social media
and the reason he was doing that as a
few reasons the primary reason he's
extremely jealous of our monumental
success
the second reason is he's jealous of our
brotherhood
because
bro logan is best friends with ksi who's
beefing jake paul does that even make
sense yeah that's weird as a brother so
logan paul went into business with ksi
they have like this massive energy drink
now and the duties legit like partners
with on this massive company has major
beef with his brother it's just like i
don't know that is just weird
you don't think so yeah you're a brother
does that even make sense bro i've had
people look at you wrong and i've
punched him in the face you know what
i'm saying
he's just so weird that's how i am with
my friends like that's just it doesn't
really make much sense well again i'd
like to hear the other side of that
story but it at face value it doesn't
sound good it sounds like a character
flaw but even still like logan paul's
[ __ ] on andrew tate on his platform
and then jake paul his brother is
defending him is defending the tates
it's just it's just like weird i mean
they're allowed to have different
opinions but no no so we sat around with
mike
mike used to say my name all the time
who's a super fan now he's saying how
much he loves the matrix i didn't know
any of this about him people keep
sending me videos the steak tastes great
on some porn star who doesn't like him
anymore and say he's a drug addict and
stuff i don't want to insult the guy
from a drug addict that sounds like a
terrible existence i've obviously never
been a drug addict because i don't make
mistakes but whatever i'm glad he's
clean
but i sat around and logan is an
extremely emotional man and you can see
on his face he's very very angry and
very very upset at our success and sits
there and tries to say no he should be
bad he should be banned and i was
watching it going the worst thing about
this is not what he's saying it's that
he doesn't really believe it
logan is a man who says things that he
because he thinks he's supposed to say
them which makes him an agent of the
matrix makes him a coward let me make
something very very clear
when i say the matrix i mean the matrix
because they have managed to alter
reality in real time by controlling
narratives by preventing the other side
of opinions to speak they convinced the
entire world to be afraid of the common
cold and anyone who stood up and said
this is asinine not even if you stood up
and said this is as9 if you just
questioned it you were shut down yeah it
was this is this is the truth there's no
other truth you can't even question it
that was it got deleted and removed they
create an alternate reality with their
platforms they create a matrix in real
time and anyone who supports that anyone
who's going to sit here and say oh
for our safety it's good that we hand
over absolute control of the world
narratives to unknown shadow figures as
long as they don't delete my account
susan
susan if i say he's a bad man susan can
i keep my account
you are a clown you are a performing
clown you have no interest
in yeah we are interested in the future
of humanity we're interested in allowing
people to have open discourse and
discussion we're interested in our
children's children living in a world
where they're not enslaved all you care
about is keeping your little [ __ ]
youtube channel because you are a
performing clown you are that's all he
is he's a performing clown and he's at
mercy he's at the mercy of his masters
and he knows it and he will say anything
he is told to [ __ ] say well this is
so sad
there was a difference between people
who
had some money became successful their
lives were impressive and then started
some social media for fun like you like
zambel's area and i've got some money
now let's take some pictures with some
girls and people who were nobodies
started doing social media and that's
all that they have that's the platform
that literally elevated them to this
their success if you take away the
platform they simply fall how long until
apple tells tristan to stop using their
computers look he's got a mac just
curious he's gonna have to switch to the
pair
yes so i can't be mad at them of course
but it's very interesting to watch where
would they be without you but no but
what's been amazing about this
cancelling is that
nothing bad has happened to me i had 700
000 followers 700 000 subscribers on
youtube i now have half a million on
rumble it's been a week i'm gonna i'm
gonna surpass it so i i'm i'm more
popular than i've ever been he only had
700 000 on youtube his youtube videos
really didn't get that many views it was
just the people that would cut them up
and then those videos would get tons of
views okay it's weird like our videos
like our first video got more views than
like what his average video would get on
his old channel he said in the video
with tucker carlson his you know target
market is 22 23 24 year old men and now
everyone all middle-aged people uh for
those of you who can't see off-camera is
my mother she's 82.
she's all she's
she's all in on hate as far as knowing
about him i don't know you know her
feelings about him whatever but she
knows all about him her friends know
about him because we're talking about
him so now that tate's been canceled
he's just blowing up generation to
generation to generation and that's
where i go back to my conspiracy theory
that they did it on purpose because they
realized that they over it's not that he
did it on purpose it's that he
recognized that it was going to happen
and he prepared for it perfectly not him
that the that the youtube that the
channels knew when they were canceling
him that he was going to blow up but did
they because everything they if they
can't see the reality that like they've
tried this with so many other people
though and it didn't work it didn't the
same effect didn't happen for alex jones
donald trump i mean they still talk
about him non-stop that's what i'm
saying donald trump every time they do
so what one more
raid all that did was was embolden trump
supporters and make them dig in more
and everything they do against him so
this is what they're doing with tate and
they're embolding his followers and now
he's getting even more popular logan is
a man who will say anything he thinks he
is supposed to say so that the people in
charge of him don't take his youtube
channel away because if he loses it he
has nothing else look okay so to me i
see this and i'm like what [ __ ] g
like he don't give a [ __ ]
right is he saying that harry styles
dressed in a dress is a g okay great
logan he looks like an [ __ ] i swear
he's not wearing a dress like your
immediate thought is wow this guy's a
real gangster yep yep cause i'm all
about champ challenging social norms
i swear i swear i i'm old school man i
like the way it is just let it ride you
just like the whole people what is it
but what is the way it is the way it's
been
you know what i love is that these kids
are looking at harry styles in a dress
like he's so bold and brave and this and
that it's like we had boy george like
george george created that like and then
you go back further you know elvis was
pushing it because he was a little racy
and sexy and all the you know 50s people
were like oh my god this is too much so
you know he's not really all that
provocative or interesting and quite
frankly the fact that the feminization
of women boy george was a gay man like
living a in a what was that a subculture
he was interesting and he was you know
bringing something new forward do you
know where that is for george of course
she knows who boy george is you know now
harry styles is doing it and he's really
just copying old [ __ ] i mean and it's
really not that interesting or
provocative and he's just doing he's
inflaming the feminization of women boy
george was a gay guy he was just being
gay and fun this guy is just being just
polluting the culture gross i don't know
sorry harry perry may be a really nice
guy face to face but the way he dresses
you look like an [ __ ] harry styles he
doesn't believe what he's saying
he's bought and sold he's a puppet it's
just clown it's true logan doesn't even
sound like he believes what he's saying
he's a g he's a tree
harry styles wearing a dress hairy
styles is a g for going on the cover of
those those are dragons
wearing pantyhose
when you're a clown right see there's a
difference between having viewers and
fans no no no but this is the truth okay
there's a difference in having viewers
and fans this is not rehearsed by the
way we should be talking about something
else how long are you going to go yeah
i'm as entertained as 71 good when you
have actual fans
they're interested in you because of
your takes and what you think right
that's different than having viewers
viewers are just gonna be you're on the
youtube algo you're youtube's poster boy
susan tells you what to say you say it
because you're scared of her like a
little girl and and people kind of tune
in but most of the people who watch your
videos and will go into this a whole
bunch of them disagree with the guy his
comments aren't even positive you watch
my videos everyone's saying top g top g
we agree we agree people love everything
we say we have no negative comments on
any of our videos the only people who
attack us are the matrix and his agents
like logan so he doesn't even have
actual fans he's a bunch of viewers and
when you have viewers you have to be
very very afraid of cancellation because
if they cancel him because he's surface
level entertainment he says nothing
profound he he stated in his videos i'm
a master or raper he's correct he's not
intelligent he can't articulate himself
correctly he doesn't say anything which
is of interest he has no genuine insight
so all he is is a clown he's a performer
he makes people laugh right haha guys
look hahaha so they take his platform
away people will just watch some other
[ __ ] content some low-level [ __ ]
content
with me they want to see what i say
they'll go anywhere i go the npc content
the droids that follow that ooh youtube
trending let me go there that kind of
stuff
oh my god i can't i remember logan
paul's content used to pop up on my feed
in like seventh grade and seeing like
younger kids watching it and i'm like
this is this is awful and you know who
james charles is seeing his makeup
videos i was just like this is just this
is cancer on a screen i can't believe
people watch this stuff well it's fine
for the people
the sliver of people that are interested
in that they should have content no the
men that want to wear makeup let them
let them watch the videos let them have
it like it's nice you know for them to
have something that's made for them
funny what he's talking about he's
talking about the the npc content just
like the stuff that people just like
just yeah i know they just watch out
watch it all day getting no substance to
their brains doing nothing with their
lives well what i was getting at is you
know then you have so there's this stuff
that's meant that you know i think
should be there for that sliver of
people that can be served by it and
enjoy it but then they they're pushing
it into the mainstream and they're
putting into other people's feeds that
don't necessarily have any interest in
that but young people are impressionable
so they think that that's normal and
commonplace and that's done on purpose
so while i think it should exist because
i believe in free speech and i believe
that everybody should have something i i
don't like the way the algorithms work
to shove this stuff down young people's
throats on purpose and that's how it's
working well you just got to know you've
got to break out of it as a young person
and just see that there's nobody sitting
there telling them well that's what they
want they want they don't want him being
able to tell people that this is
junk and to do something that's the
whole point right different i have fans
he only has viewers and when you only
have viewers you have to be very very
afraid because you are beholden to the
matrix in and of itself also guys you
know that we are not necessarily inside
of the matrix make sure to follow us on
rumble as well where all full uncensored
videos will be yeah it's hard to get out
because i mean we we've been saying how
we feel regardless of what youtube
thinks and they've taken down a few
videos so definitely go check us out on
rumble stay in touch and join the
discord got cancelled he cried his
little eyes out he said oh i think he
even said in this video he made about me
when you get canceled you know andrew's
pretending he doesn't care he's some
stoic warrior but i know how much it
hurts logan
it hurt you
because you're a [ __ ] and logan also
made like a massive mistake so like when
he's getting ridiculed for something
that he actually did that was bad yeah
you're gonna feel worse than when tate's
just saying stuff to help men and then
apologize for that yeah you apologize
like a million times because i don't i
don't necessarily believe in apologizing
unless it's wrong unless it deserves an
apology and i from what little i know
now i think that did deserve an apology
like showing somebody's dead child's
hanging from a tree people make mistakes
for entertainment deserved an apology
and he apologized so what you know
that's good that's make mistakes too i
mean when you're when you're famous from
the age of like 15 and you you hit 20
and you you know right you're thinking
it's going to happen
the same thing with ksi and making those
creeps anybody could have any anybody
except for tate who said he doesn't make
mistakes anybody could have made that
mistake as a young person i'm glad he
apologized for it i think where tate is
where i agree with tate is that you've
got people apologizing for every little
thing yeah and it's it and it's to the
point where stop apologizing because
you're not really sorry you don't mean
it you're just afraid of the matrix and
you're afraid of the punishment and
that's where it makes you a loser tate
is right don't do that grandma has my
swearing been been better this video
yeah that's what have i been swearing no
i'm good okay good you've been good i
gotta have grandma we gotta have grandma
sitting here all the time so you curse
less yeah this is the cheat code i'm
gonna take it to church
i've been taking it to church it doesn't
work the funniest was when we were on
call with sneko and he's like you can
say you can say [ __ ] in front of your
mom and you're like yeah this kid does
[ __ ] sway too much when are we
talking to sneaker again sneaker let's
get on a call again that was fun
is he ghosting us it goes no i dm him we
talk still he's going through a lot with
like getting censored on social media
platforms so i just if there's anything
we can do it's nico you know we got you
let's let's have them on at least let's
do something collab
i've been saying i'm gonna get canceled
for the last two years our life was
exactly the same two years before this
when no one on the internet knew who we
were i don't mean you do we've been
living well for for a decade now a
decade logan needs youtube to matter and
that's why when susan called him and
said listen we've attempted to attack
the top g we're trying to control the
narrative we hope that you have some
kind of scope and some kind of control
over the youth even though you don't we
would like you to go sit there and for
you to say that it's good that we've
banned him and we're going to talk about
why they did that because they did a
massive mistake in banning me but first
let's understand something about logan
logan is a [ __ ] let's all look at logan
cry i don't feel like giving him the
blessing of being my dance partner in
the ring i don't feel like platforming
this guy backlash against a social media
star didn't you box me like didn't he
box mayweather no
look and fall
he's like i don't feel like platforming
this guy you boxed mayweather he's a way
crappy yeah
boxer yeah logan paul did boxing you you
box mayweather that's he's a way worse
person that dude has countless scams i
can name multiple pyramid schemes he's
worked for crypto scams same with this
dude floyd mayweather tons of stuff with
women
floyd mayweather little baby guy boxed
mayweather he's he's a big guy he's like
a ton of pounds on him mayweather's also
50 years old yeah he's 50 and but he's
also one of the best boxers in the world
he's over 15-0 it's a 50-year-old 50-0
boxer against logan paul who's big
jacked and has a couple years in boxing
pretty boring fight to watch not gonna
lie but who posted video of an apparent
suicide victim is intensifying this has
been the hardest time of my life i've
never been
hated by the whole world and it's been
something to definitely overcome do you
deserve a second chance would you say
everyone deserves second chance as well
and you take got banned from the
internet i don't feel like giving him
the blessing of being my dad the problem
with logan is not that he disagrees with
me
because if you're a crazy feminist and
you genuinely disagree with me and you
want to come along and say oh i hate
andrew ditto fine you're wrong but at
least you believe what you say
logan's not the kind of person who
genuinely disagrees with me logan's the
kind of person who gets a piece of paper
before his show
with instructions
okay and he complies obviously that's a
metaphor he doesn't actually get that
but he's just it's just he's saying that
he follows the matrix and what he can
and can't say so he doesn't get his
platform removed
ultimately he's a puppet his businesses
all rely on his platform everything does
right his life would fall apart if he
didn't have this where tate's already
got hundreds of millions of dollars and
all the things he could ever want well i
just gave tate a few thousand more today
the war room cost money to join wow i
know it does but i didn't know you're
welcome top g but i'll be a high value
man now my muscles already got bigger
since i joined and he wasn't giving his
genuine opinion either he was giving a
list of talking points and he was told
what to say because he's a mouthpiece of
the matrix he's an agent you know i
actually watched that clip and i don't
really care what these people say
logan's never said my name jake's never
said my name i've never said theirs i
don't care what these people say but
there was a part in it when they were
trying to name the dangerous things you
said and that logan's boyfriend came up
with that oh well you know he said you
can't give cpr to your friend because
because uh that's gay now let me explain
something to you they don't listeners
out there young men of the world because
i know a lot of young men watch and
follow me and follow my brother and
listen to our opinions they
underestimate your intelligence severely
these fully grown men these adults over
18 years of age over 40 some of these
men will sit there and say that that's a
dangerous thing to say to young men as
though you as youngsters are incapable
of understanding a [ __ ] joke me and
my brother are the two closest people in
the world we're both you saw that clip
right where he's like i will not give
anyone but a hot woman cpr well how
about how about during that clip i made
a comment that i would not if there was
some skeevy person on the street i would
just let them die and the only people
who i would give cpr to are were you and
the dog right so i made this comment
look grandma's shaking her head she
ain't giving anybody cpr either
it runs in the family but i made this
comment and
i said and then in the comments on that
video someone's like you're a horrible
person that you give a dog cpr before a
human i'm like give the dog cpr before
me
like first of all i was joking okay i
wasn't joking but still lighting up like
would just don't choke to death in front
of me and you won't have a problem with
it yeah come on come on bring your own
get up bring your own person might as
well want to buy a cigarette drink a
coffee get back in the game yeah but for
him to say that and people to [ __ ] all
over him on that like again i say this
all the time imagine what it's like to
just have no sense of humor and it is an
insult to all the young people to think
that they can't they can't understand
the joke everything do we have this
whole they think this movement is just
be so serious and literal at all times
and it they have no sense of humor and
then they say that you know the other
side we're all demons you can't joke
about anything back in the day right
let's just go back to as far as world
war ii it was so much easier to feed
propaganda to people because they had
the nazis had their own radio network
and they blocked signals from outside
the country so peop if you were living
in the country you were just constantly
told the germans are winning the war
everything is good the jews are bad
we're the best we're the master race and
you couldn't get the other signals
except if they came in you know secret
squirrels some people had some
underground messaging coming in yeah but
imagine like hearing that you'd be like
this guy's a crazy conspiracy theorist
what is he talking about right but
nowadays with the technology that we
have there is everybody has access to
all the information it's all there so if
you're still being fooled by any kind of
propaganda you're an [ __ ] and that is
your fault and your problem for not
peeling off the layers one by one and
saying okay let me i do i want to
believe this let me go deeper let me
look deeper and making up your own minds
back then it was you were literally
insulated now if you're buying into this
it's your own fault they don't even
teach you how to think in school they
just teach you how to comply how to how
to follow the the exact guidelines they
give you like like mla mla format like
if you don't if you don't do this exact
format you lose 20 of your grades you're
not gonna that's what that's what's so
important to you these teachers they
bought over stuff like that you didn't
psychic you get an f it's ridiculous
grandma you didn't like that one huh no
because the teachers are doing what they
had told
because they were also in the matrix
yeah
the teachers are like the deepest in the
major we talk about having that voice
back brotherhood caring about each other
watching out for each other all the time
if you
they really believe
that not only if i had a heart attack
andrew wouldn't give me cpr they
believed that you would listen to this
and watch your friend have a heart
attack and say can't give him cpr
because top g wouldn't what am i gay i'm
not giving you cpr they genuinely
believe that people are going to die and
not get the medical attention they need
because of a joke that andrew made these
adults purport the lie that you
youngsters are stupid enough to believe
that so you're being severely
underestimated and you're giving these
people your time and your attention and
your money on super chats and the ad
revenue close their [ __ ] channels
just like just stop watching that [ __ ]
because they think you're punks they
think you're idiots they do think you're
stupid follow us on rumble link is in
the description i'm going to keep saying
it every video so just do it and logan
is a mouthpiece to the eight for the
making that's what's been the most
eye-opening thing for me people always
say what's it like to get banned andrew
because they banned all your social
media and they banned your payment
processor and they banned your banks
listen
listen bravo
i gave you how did you pay him
cryptocurrency baby
i bet he still takes cash everybody
switched to cash look at him pause this
facebook you can tell paypal and venmo
and the government and everybody to
stick their banking up their butt we
want or cash they can't they can't
follow you look you've heard of like the
cases where people have gotten like
pulled over driving and they have like
twenty thousand dollars in cash and the
government and then the police take it
and then they're like you need to
provide you need to prove where you got
this money from and it is a lot of these
people just never got their money back
it's the same thing but if your money's
in the bank they don't question it makes
no sense makes no sense they have
control over it you heard about that
right i do know that they they get there
are certain amounts in certain places
and certain avenues that you people lost
tens of thousands of dollars and they
just never got it back it's crazy if you
think i haven't been on the internet
knowing that ban is coming for a very
long time and preparing myself in every
single possible way you're absolutely
incorrect if you think they're going to
delete a few things of mine and i'm
going to have any kind of trouble in my
life you are absolutely not really
incorrect
that's an american fighter jet
it's neo we live near the airport in
bucharest vermeina and nato
they do some stuff around here ukraine's
next door so they're launching planes
anyway i've been prepared for this for a
very very long time so
it doesn't bother me
in that regard hard to kill but what it
has been good for
is identifying which
members of
the allowed
famous public perceptive the people who
are allowed to have a platform right
because they're allowed by certain
individuals
who's been full of [ __ ] and who hasn't
and i've learned and been pleasantly
surprised by some characters to realize
they're truly about it and speak the
truth and i've watched some fold in real
time scared to be scared to even be
associated in any kind of semi-positive
way even though they know it's bad for
humanity they don't care the clown needs
his platform that's all he gives a [ __ ]
about to be fair his brother jake
tweeted that you shouldn't have been bad
jake yeah because jake's the real
brother well i followed jake i even
messaged jake an inbox on saying you i
appreciate the tweet probably didn't see
it i'm small fry on instagram compared
to jake but i literally thanked him i
could delete that man this dude is so
clueless almost small fry on instagram
compared to jake bruv you're like one of
the most famous people in the world now
what are you talking about jake paul
doesn't see my dm's no he's he's having
a moment of modesty leave it alone his
one moment of modesty just busting your
balls message you know good for him
that's good for him standing up for
what's right bro [ __ ] logan's such a
snake he's [ __ ] friends with the dude
who beats his own brother he also made a
diss track about his brother i don't
know if you've heard it i couldn't sit
the whole way this is the problem with
people like logan they are not smart
enough to see beyond themselves and
their clown act and understand that when
there's a group of people who control
absolutely everything in terms of
narratives what can be said what must be
believed
when you have these kind of people on a
long enough time period they will turn
tyrannical there is no way they don't
become tyrannical the only way you can
you can prevent that is to have balance
within the universe
you think that these people really want
the best for you these people on top
don't just want to control you and that
they won't do anything to control you i
can't even go into the crazy conspiracy
theories that i that i truly believe on
youtube i'm like afraid to somehow like
afraid to talk about that stuff right
now maybe down the line if we're just
like strictly on rumble but oh let's do
it on rubble oh it's disgusting we
should have rumble exclusive videos
where we need to say everything because
it's not i don't want to i'm not afraid
to get banned on youtube i don't care
it's not even about getting banned it's
about like oh he's he's saying that like
i don't know who cares i don't give a
[ __ ] you know i don't care yeah i'm good
uh i'll pause for now like with that
stuff like crazy conspiracy stuff forces
that's what's so important i don't even
consider myself right wing i'm not a
right-wing guy however i'm a political
i'm a political i don't give a [ __ ]
about politics don't care about biden
don't care about trump however i believe
alex jones is super important why is it
because it's politics no because he is
the polar opposite to the woke [ __ ]
feminism and you need to have opposites
if you delete all the opposites then
you're gonna create a tyrannical world
if logan paul had half a brain and he
had any substances a man he'd sit there
and go this is actually important for
the world this is bigger than my clown
face [ __ ] this is bigger than my
youtube channel this is actually a
really important thing like his brother
understood he is so selfish and
self-centered he's just too busy talking
about harry styles looking hot in a
dress the guy's a [ __ ] idiot the guy
is literally a genuinely stupid
individual he's not smart he's a dumb
man and the problem is with him not only
is he dumb he's a sellout he's an agent
for the matrix so from now on logan's
name is agent and you know what's
actually interesting when i got sent
these clips
someone sent this to me about five
minutes before we went live i didn't see
i didn't see many of them and i also
don't care but just the [ __ ] he said
about his brother for me that's hard to
wrap my mind around it really is it
really is that's why me and you were a
team of multi-millionaires before we
even got on social media i think because
of that so were we multi multi deaths
and millionaires before we started this
youtube channel
that we have so i just don't like that
in general diss track about his brother
it's weird
so i'm trying to find a way to make
these fit on the screen but i got sent
so i someone said have you have you seen
the comments on his twitter on his
videos i said no i haven't i haven't
even gone i haven't looked someone sent
me a few of these so let's look through
it
this guy is always going to bow down to
the companies that made him famous
many people like logan are just jealous
of the tate's fame and how quick he was
able to rise up
fact check true
same guy involved in multiple crypto
scams fact check true how many cryptos
have i launched with my influence think
how much crypto i could launch so this
dude could make the this dude could make
bitcoin hate bitcoin and it would be
bigger than regular right he could make
take coin so
logan paul was involved in some crypto
scams is what he's saying yeah both of
them him and his brother were both
involved in multiple crypto scams okay
all right wow
again you know i'm actually not going to
go rumor that's where i'm are okay what
is the crypto scams as far as my first
hearing about it it's rumor i'll look
into it i know the people that they did
it with it's not okay
all right let's let's skip it here but
tell me more about it later please yeah
think about how i could launch a crypto
and be bigger than any of the nft trash
either of them [ __ ] and how many
times have people said i will do this
i'll make the take coin and what do we
do no you say no because i say i've made
my money
i'm already rich i'm not ripping anyone
a single fan of mine puts in his last
hundred dollars and loses ten of it i
won't be able to sleep at night correct
i will not have that we don't that is
such a good role model that's the people
that they're cancelling that's insane
this dude literally just you know how
many influencers were selling out in the
peak in the peak of like nfts and crypto
just constantly like promoting like
whatever bs they could and he's saying
that if one of my followers lost money
how upset i would be that is such a good
influence to all people watching him all
content creators it's such a good
message it is i feel the same way i used
to i was so passionate about my old
company and even now with my university
i'm putting like so much time into it
launch crypto pump and dumps we don't
launch scams we're not trying to grab
money we're not selling shitty energy
drinks the only thing we had
was an online university and they're
gonna pretend we're bad for teaching
people how to make websites [ __ ]
unbelievable look at this guy look at
the next one
isn't that crazy that they got so
ridiculed oh excuse me thank you for
singing excuse me cuz grandma's here
they got so ridiculed for having an
online university like ah just go jump
down i'm done enough
the guy took a video of a man who
committed suicide is disapproving of a
man who shared his beliefs it's all the
people who listen to him to give him
what they say logan is ridiculous these
are his own viewers his own fans he he's
got fans these are the people on his own
[ __ ] who just know he's full of [ __ ] you
know that's what's gross about this
situation is that logan who you know put
up the suit poor suit guy in the suicide
situation apologized managed to keep his
platform and continue to grow his fame
and then doesn't have the compassion
even to look at somebody else who didn't
even make a mistake because not the
compassion to look at somebody else who
was cancelled and and treat it with with
dignity and decency in fact instead he's
like yeah kick him while he's down it
tells me also that logan after that
whole suicide situation didn't grow as a
person and didn't didn't learn anything
from it that his apology
now seems hollow after that everyone
knows logan's full of [ __ ] we don't care
if i have to get banned for people to
wake up and realize which of the people
out here with influence are simply
agents of the matrix that's worth it so
i'm glad that people are starting to
come out and you're you're rich anyway
i'm rich anyway is he wearing silver
talking about rachel we're talking about
a minute but first let's do the super
chats all right okay
are those still pajamas don't they look
like some pajamas it doesn't look like
an outside
jacket like a smoke maybe like a smoking
jacket
okay yeah like a smoking jacket i want
to smoke cigars in the videos can i
smoke in here grandma
no we have to get silk smoking jackets
if we ever get on like a robe
i have a surprise for if we get on when
we get on a call with tate i have a
surprise oh good hi teresa hi teresa's
here what's up oh the children are
fighting logan paul coward to the matrix
pretty obvious he's an agent would you
give him one to ten on pretty eyes logan
has a nine
right what is this [ __ ] he does oh my
god
i think he's handsome he's got a nine on
the on the pretty eyes
why is that what you mentioned first
this whole video is about powering to
the matrix and you first thing you say
is he has pretty eyes
show his eyes this is that's
wow that's that's
this is the dude he has pretty eyes and
he has nice long eyelashes what are you
gonna do
that's your boy that's your boy with his
pretty eyes wow he's dead so handsome
he's got pretty muscles too light has
nice eyelashes too there in that picture
but anyway what is this the eyelashes
channel go go go collab with james
charles i'm done with this give him a
reading
schmel you later based on what i know so
far i'm gonna give him a three and the
reason the reason i'm i'm holding back
fully on my judgment is because when i
first met tate on my first hate video i
gave him a six because i only knew
what's that you give him a zero but you
watched part of the tucker carlson today
did you give him a hi did he go up from
zero at all after that well you give tay
to zero you and i watch part of the of
the tucker carlson
video you give tate zero you said my
first reaction
today and what you've seen between then
and today when you watch part of the
taco carlson interview he went up a bit
to what
she's [ __ ] icy and hard so don't take
him personal date what do you get you
might be watching this come on you got a
four today a four four oh my god wow how
generous of you that's an eight and
everyone else's mind tate okay just so
you know she's hard what am i grandma
all right i told you i gave him a three
but if i hadn't heard three in a pretty
eyes congrats logan 2.5 logan 2.5 you're
down what is his eye eyelashes not
straight enough literally all right guys
so much for watching i'm giving a
hundred dollars something like
subscribes join the discord in my bio
the get [ __ ] done university we're
launching very soon uh the first 1000
people get in for a cheaper rate uh and
it's gonna sell out quick so definitely
be in there i'm doing multiple live
calls i have a video about my business
stuff in there check it out smile later
say
[Music]
later writing on the wall won't last
long yeah